oui laser des feux pénalise les plus
pauvres et oui c'est une bombe sociale
parce qu'il y a aujourd'hui 10 millions
d'automobilistes qui ont des véhicules
de critères 3 4 5 qui vont être
interdits de se déplacer tout simplement
quand ils habitent une petite commune je
voudrais vous rappeler que ces et des
feux qui sont une mesure de santé
publique ça n'est pas une invention
française ça existe dans 270 villes
européennes et vous l'avez dit il y a
des difficultés potentielles pour les
plus modestes tu en as aussi contenu de
cette pollution si vous avez une
vignette critère 5 ou 4 sur votre
voiture vous ne pouvez peut-être plus
circuler dans certaines villes et ça
c'est dû à la loi d'orientation des
mobilités de 2019 qui a instauré les ZFE
instruments inégalitaires outils de
lutte contre la pollution qu'en est-il
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans
factures
faible émission mobilité c'est un
secteur où la circulation des voitures
peut être limitée pour y circuler un
certificat qualité de l'air est
obligatoire les véhicules les plus
polluants
identifiés par les vignettes critères 5
4 et 3 peuvent être soumis à des
restrictions de circulation actuellement
11 métropoles ont mis en place une ZFE
parmi elles Grand Paris Lyon
Aix-Marseille Toulouse ou encore
Strasbourg et Grenoble d'ici 2025 les 43
agglomérations de plus de 150 000
habitants devront avoir instauré une ZFE
soit 32 supplémentaires ce sont les
collectivités locales qui fixent le
périmètre et le temps pour le faire même
si certaines métropoles vont être
obligées d'accélérer leur calendrier car
leurs émissions ne respectent pas le
seuil européen réglementaire alors à
quoi servent ces zones à faible émission
l'objectif des ETF est d'améliorer la
qualité de l'air pour estimer leurs
bénéfices l'Observatoire Régional de
Santé d'Île-de-France a développé avec
er-parif et santé publique France une
évaluation prospective cette nouvelle
étape de la de la téléphone donc l'étape
qui correspond à l'interdiction des
critères 4 en juin 2021
elle va permettre de baisser les
émissions liées au trafic routier de
l'ordre de 8% pour le dioxyde pour les
oxyde d'azote de l'ordre de 4% pour les
particules dites PM10 et de l'ordre de
6% pour les particules fines de 5 en
France la pollution atmosphérique est
responsable chaque année de 48 000 décès
prématurés selon santé publique France
et le secteur des transports routiers
représente une source majeure des
missions polluantes cette nouvelle étape
de la cdfe elle entraîne une baisse de
la mortalité liée à la pollution de
l'air avec 50 décès par an éviter et ça
dès la première année et entraîne aussi
une baisse sur la morbidité avec 520 cas
d'asthme évitez aussi dès la première
année rappelons qu'en Île-de-France un
décès sur 10 et lié à la pollution de
l'air selon le ministre de la transition
écologique Christophe Béchu les premiers
résultats sont encourageants il
expliquait à Santé Magazine en octobre
dernier qu'en 2017 13 métropoles
dépassaient les seuils européens
réglementaires de qualité de l'air ce
chiffre serait descendu à 8 métropoles
en 2020 à 5 en 2021 et aujourd'hui trois
métropoles seraient encore en
dépassement de seuil Paris Lyon et
Marseille si la solution des ETFE a une
efficacité sanitaire et climatique elle
pose un autre type de problème la mesure
est jugée antisociale puisqu'elle touche
particulièrement les plus modestes 30,8%
des populations les plus pauvres
disposent encore de voitures critères 4
5 et non classé soit les plus polluantes
10% parmi les ménages les plus riches
ça demande à des gens qui circulent dans
les zones concernées de le faire avec
des véhicules beaucoup plus récents pour
la plupart que ceux qui le possèdent ça
implique donc qu'il les renouvellent et
les calendriers tels qu'ils ont été mis
en place ils sont irréalistes dans le
sens où ça réclame une multiplication
par 3 ou 4 de la vitesse de
renouvellement des véhicules ce qui est
très compliqué surtout surtout dans une
période où elle se trouve que le
matériel manque disponibilité des
véhicules d'occasion récents sur
électrique et très limité les prix sont
très élevés pour parler ce problème une
surprise a été instaurée en effet la
mise en place d'une ZFE s'accompagne
d'un supplément à la prime à la
conversion lors de l'achat ou de la
location d'un véhicule peu polluant si
dans le même temps un ancien véhicule
diesel ou essence est mis à la casse le
montant de cette surprise est identique
à l'adversé par la collectivité
territorial dans la limite de 1000 euros
les primes à la conversion sont plutôt
bien pensées on pourrait même dire que
aller jusqu'à dire que les montants sont
significatifs et peuvent être suffisants
le souci c'est que il y a beaucoup de
non recours parce que les populations
qui sont concernées ciblés sont des
populations comme qui ont des véhicules
anciens qui les achètent de particuliers
particuliers qui les renouvellent
les épisodiquement donc ils sont pas
forcément au courant quand bien même
vous êtes au courant après vous allez la
plupart des cas de voir faire face à un
montage aussi administratif selon un
sondage réalisé par Le Figaro le 24
octobre dernier
69% de nos lecteurs n'étaient pas
favorables à l'élargissement des aidefe
dans les villes contre 31% face aux
critiques le gouvernement a signé un
décret selon lequel l'obligation
d'instaurer une ZFE est écartée lorsque
les concentrations moyennes annuelles
ont dioxyde d'azote sont inférieurs ou
égal à 10 grammes par au cube soit le
seuil fixé par l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé mais cette dérogation ne
devrait pas concerner plus d'une dizaine
d'agglomérations selon le ministère de
la transition écologique aujourd'hui
certains demandent toujours une
augmentation de la prime à la conversion
ou une amélioration des réseaux de
transport en commun l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes exigent que
tous les véhicules qui passent avec
succès le contrôle technique qui
comprend désormais un volet pollution
puisse continuer à circuler dans les ade
[Musique]